وفي الحديث عن حكم القانون الالاف من
انصارق اصلا في السجن كمن سحب العشرات من
قاده حزبك ايضا
يمكن حظر هذا الحزب هل تمر بازمه كبيره
الان
هي ليست ازمه حزبي بل هي ازمه البلاد في
باكستان حاليا
لدينا حكم الغاب ولا يوجد حكم القانون
القضاء تم تقويضه بالكامل
والاعلام
ايضا اسكت تفاهه بالكامل اخرس بالكامل
ويسيطرن عليه بالكامل حزب السياسي وهو
اكبر حزب سياسي باكستان
دوار
واجهه اكبر عملياته قمع العشره الالاف هي
السجون وحتى القيادات العليا في السجون
اكثر من 150 قضيه رفعت ضدي
فما يحصل هو انه من خلال محاولتهم لتفكيك
حزبي
الديمقراطيه باكملها في باكستان تم
تفكيكها وهذا هو القلق الحقيقي اذا ما
دمرنا ديمقراطيه اي بلد فبالتالي ينمر
مستقبله